[Applause]
it wasn't the landslide many had
predicted it may not even be a win
it could be days before we know what it
is but joe biden
is still projecting confidence he will
be the next president
we feel good about where we are
we really do
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
we knew because of the unprecedented
early vote in the mail-in vote
that's going to take a while we're going
to have to be patient
until we uh the hard work of tallying
the votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
[Applause]
it was brief and designed to keep the
faithful enthused
for what could be a protracted battle
and as biden was speaking the president
was tweeting
confident but as many expected casting
doubt on the process
we are up big he wrote but they're
trying to steal the election
we will never let them do it votes
cannot be cast
after the polls are closed twitter
flagged it for
possible misinformation it was a
contentious claim
that could end up in the courts
donald trump had told us time and again
not to write him off
election night headed for mourning with
him again making those disputed claims
of wrongdoing
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
on the streets of washington the
uncertainty has fed a febrile atmosphere
discontent with trump and nervousness
about which way the country's heading
as we'd suspected all along it will be
those rust belt states
of pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin
that will decide america's path forward
[Music]
biden's supporters remain confident i
wish this would have been resolved
earlier
but you know we have to keep the hope
alive i mean joe biden's such a
wonderful man
he's such a wonderful ethical he's going
to bring the country together
and that's what we're hoping for i'm
still very positive
you know vice president biden's going to
be our next president it's going to take
a little longer than we thought
and so uh we're optimistic you know
we're just used to we're americans we're
used to having things quickly and now
we've got to be a little more patient
america's and the world's next four
years
are hanging in the balance greg milam
sky news wilmington in delaware